oh nicola i am
i'm so excited to talk to you i'm
overwhelmed oh that's so nice thank you
you look beautiful
what a weekend 12 nominations for
bridgerton at the emmys we could pretend
to form an attachment
[Music]
indeed
every presumptuous mother in town will
leave me alone and every suitor will be
looking at you
how did you all react when you first
heard the news like was the group chad
just going off it was amazing it was so
exciting i think it's the biggest awards
in in television so
to be recognized by them is phenomenal
we were all super excited we're in the
middle of filming season two right now
so it's it's the new it's the new season
two group chat was going off it's called
bridger ii
that name and felt very proud i felt
like that's so smart
but i still liked it well bridgerton is
many things and one of them is clever um
okay well this makes sense because we
did hear is it true that reggae said he
respectfully left the group chat
we also but then we also like didn't
tell him well because he because he's
not in it
there's a new one but we're like it's
okay you know we we respect his decision
we're like you go fly fly free right
yeah the bridge or two chat
it's hopping off honestly there's always
things happening on not much i can tell
you about but yeah
i was you know i was gonna ask okay
you're like
fly a little bird go be james bond next
i mean that would be amazing wouldn't it
be great i mean well let's clarify were
you guys sad to see him how did you all
react to the news though that he wasn't
doing season two i mean of course you
were sad you know why i mean we've
created a family in bridgeton and it's
also it's based on these books so
there's the world of the books we would
have loved him to stay of course but i
always tell people it's a bit like jess
when jesse left little mix
you know i always think like yes we're
sad that he's decided to leave but we
respect the decision and we're excited
for the things that we're creating you
know
okay give can you give me one thing
that's on the bridge or two group text
oh yeah totally so basically our our
icon is a picture of kate and anthony
and kate is the queen so kate sharma
who's our new leading lady she's the
queen and then anthony bridgeton is a
corgi it's from a fan site
and i yeah i thought that was the
perfect picture
i love it we're having a big day of
filming tomorrow and i cannot tell you
what it is but everyone is there so
we're all very excited we're all
currently texting and i can't wait for
tomorrow
well can you give me one hint about what
it is
i'll be wearing yellow
i love it he's a corgi so that means
she's kind of maybe she's queen
she's boxing around do you want to see
it yes
okay let me look okay so bridger two
i have us on airplanes so you know we
don't but here we go
that's kate and anthony they're
obsessed
yeah i mean thank you to the fan that
made that we love it how will you all
celebrate will you watch together since
you're all together it'll probably be at
like 2 a.m for us maybe
i'm filming the next day so i will be
asleep
or very glamorous isn't it can i pitch
something to you keep your costumes on
yes stay up drink champagne and watch
the emmys in the bridgerton costumes
if you say it's okay larry and i'm gonna
be like lauren told me it was fine so
you have to let us do it so who is going
from the cast then reggae is going right
i think he's going again i don't
but i'm sure i'm sure he will go and
look very handsome and beautiful and
yeah then the rest of us will be in our
pjs making more bridgeton which come on
that's very important which we all want
okay you can't have completely cut off
all contact from him though or if not no
no not at all no
he's the busiest man in the world he's
like the internet's boyfriend and that
comes with a lot of responsibilities so
now he did just he kind of played coy
and he teased a little bit that maybe
the duke will be back for a cameo
not that i have hurt
but they could surprise us still i
haven't i haven't seen anything to
reflect that okay but it could happen
stranger things have happened lauren who
knows we never know with bridgerton you
never know
can you help the fans understand as you
said it goes by the books and each book
is a different story we're so excited
for anthony's story but how will that
work if daphne's still there how will we
explain that the duke isn't there
i mean the thing is
daphne and anthony have such a good
relationship
and he involved himself so much in her
in the duke that's now daphne's turn to
be like i'm gonna be involved in what
you're doing i'm gonna figure out you
know and there's a lot going on it's
extremely dramatic claudia jesse and i
who plays eloise literally sat in my
trailer yesterday going and people are
gonna die when this happens and they're
gonna die and this happens and they're
not gonna believe that and it's it's
amped up
it's very hard it's gonna be months
before i can say what any of this thing
that i'm referring to is but it's it's
it's very epic this year i feel like i'm
gonna describe it okay
the duke is busy he's the duke is
playing james bond
in 1814 so that's what he's doing i'm
going to get them to write that in it's
not on the script yet but i will get
them well we we learned i think we
learned your character's secret identity
at the end of season one where will we
find penelope in season two
perhaps i will come forward one day
though you must know dear reader that
decision shall be left entirely up to me
yours truly
lady whistled down
it's gotten a whole lot spicier i would
say you oh how much can i say
you definitely see more sides to her i
think you know we find out at the end of
season one that
that is there but we don't get to
explore it but like the world cracks
open i feel like the bridge of tomorrow
just has grown and you're gonna see a
lot more size to her she is
she's a sassy chick
oh i love it she's got that that feather
quill in her hand serving off she does
um so i mean fans were so excited
to hear about season two season one the
response explosive twelve emmy
nominations how did that make you all
feel heading into season two i mean
nerves uh did you wanna up the ante
where were you guys all at mentally as a
cast
you know what it's it's such an exciting
thing when you do
a show that anyone watches and connects
to but the level at which people
connected to bridgeton and the scale is
really mind-blowing
but i think we weirdly went in more
relaxed which i know maybe some people
wouldn't but we just i think we felt so
much love from the fans of the show and
support and also this
season the book which this season is
based on is like the big fan favorite so
we you know when you do season one you
don't know if you're gonna get a season
two but we were like i really hope we
get a chance to tell that story because
people love it so much and kate is such
a fiery character she's like this strong
independent woman so we really wanted to
get to that and the fact that we get to
tell it is a real privilege
and yeah and i think there's also the
fun of a second season that you don't
have to do the exposition you want to be
like oh this is the world bridges people
get what bridgeton is now and it's
become like this phenomenon which is
bonkers but yeah people know what
they're heading into but
they are not ready okay by the way uh
speaking of fans i mean you've got huge
ones including the kardashians
when i saw you said you're such a big
fan that you talked about the
kardashians when you were creating a
featherington
so i mean when you
get here from kim k and you invited her
to a fitting did she ever come will we
see her in season two make a cameo so
kim and i
are like this well no we have we've dm'd
back and forth which is so surreal like
i am a big kardashian fan i've been
watching those calabasas ladies for many
many years and in my first fitting ella
mirage nick who designed season one said
you're she was like you're the
kardashians of regency london she was
like you're fabulous and you're over the
top and you're this and we've got the
ambitious mama and the three daughters
and we all are like oh i'm kim you're
like well obviously i'm kim but penelope
we agree lauren you and i is kim of
course
she's the one who's the entrepreneur
she's the best
you know longevity and him is she's i
had heard how lovely she was and she is
so nice and
she's like such a fan of the show it's
just it's very crazy but yeah i love it
gotta get her in for a fitting like i'm
wanting to sneak him in a cameo on
season two 100 lady cat lady calabasas i
can't wait oh now if you uh again kim k
we've had who else has slid into your
dms there's gotta be other babies oh
gosh who else i mean sarah jessica
parker follows me on instagram but i'm
like two i'm too scared to dmr i mean i
love her so much not just sex in the
city hocus pocus first wife's club like
she's
just so wonderful i i love her drew
barrymore we we spoke with her
and she was just so wonderful and
supportive about the show and how can
you not love her i haven't spoken to
billy porter but i've seen billy porter
talk about it i love and adore him
so
can we say it's a guarantee we'll see
you stick with bridgerton because we
need to see penelope's book penelope's
got a lot of things still to do i am i
trust me i'm sticking around because
that book is spicy electric
shocking
[Music]
you